hi welcome to this joint ab and scrutiny
committee I'm councelor James Casten and
I'm chairing this meeting today may I
first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements if you're attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the me meeting you may be
asked to leave please ensure your mobile
phones and laptops are on
silent we will be using EV voting for
this meeting on the modern. goov app the
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph and
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
if you are intending if if you are
intending to film please inform form the
committee clerk on hearing the fire
alarm please leave the building via the
fire exits and make your way to the
assembly point on Ipswich toown football
pitch follow the sign directing you to
the fire exits at the end of each floor
do not enter the atrium ground floor
area or walkways if you are in the
atrium at the time of the alarm please
follow the signs to the nearest fire
exit use the stairs not the lifts and do
not re-enter the building until it's
your told it's safe to do
so excuse me so um this is our um budget
scrutiny meeting um first of all I'd
quite like to go around and just um
introduce everyone so um starting with
um Rachel would you like to introduce
yourself um to the cameras thank you
chair um my name is Rachel eburn and I'm
a District counselor and the cabinet
member for finance and resources good
morning
everybody thank
you morning Jenny smiies I'm the H
Finance business
partner good morning I'm Sean cter I'm
the senior Finance business partner for
Revenue good morning my name is Karen
Watling I'm the interim corporate
manager for
finance Tom one of the directors of
council right okay thank you um I'll
move to the agenda um apologies for
absence sorry non received
chair to receive Declarations of
pecuniary other registerable or non-reg
interest by
members um are there any to
declare
no to confirm the minutes of the last
mids suffk um scrutiny meeting on the 20
of of November
2023 um has everyone had a chance to go
through those and are there any
issues no could I have a proposal for
those please councilor scarf and a
seconder councelor Pearson and um we'll
do that on the electronic vote it's all
set up for you if You' like to go
through thank you chair that vote is now
in
progress councilor Piper can I take your
vote verbally
please um thank you chair that is four
votes for and one AB ition that's
carried okay thank you that's carried
they're fine so um the next item four to
receive notifications of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme none received chair questions by
the public none received chair questions
by counselors none received chair right
so now to the um the general fund and
housing revenue account
M
so um can I invite the Rachel Eber and
the cabinet member to introduce the
report to committee
please um thank you very much chair
thank you members um and thank you for
inviting me um here today um this is an
opportunity for for you as a committee
to review where we're at with the
budgets for mids suffk so I look forward
to hearing any comments um and
recommendations you might have um but
please note this is work in progress so
no final decisions will be made until
full Council on the 22nd of February um
what we've got in front of you today is
the the two budgets for the council the
general fund and the HRA so on the on
the general fund first the key
differences from 23 24 um as you'll see
in the papers are increase in employee
costs a decrease in fees and charges
mainly from
planning and also just note that the
supplies and services um is shown as an
increase as this was um money that was
in reserves so it was actual kind of
council work that was funded through
reserves and I feel anything the council
is doing day-to-day should actually be
included in the budget so that was put
into the
budget in terms of the financing of this
um as we all know interest rates have
have gone up although they've they've
steadied a bit but um that affects both
borrowing and
Investments um on the business rates
we're still a waiting for confirmation
of government figures which we should
get at the end of this month um so what
this space um within the council tax
amounts in that your paper you've got it
shows a 2% increase and also the
proposed changes to empty homes rates
and um also the increase in the tax base
of
2.8% the other point to note about the
financing of the general fund is you'll
note that there's a large Gateway 14
dividend now this might change in terms
of that overall amount available for 24
5 but it is indicative of the kind of
sums of of money involved so just to
make you aware of that and on reserves
we've been we've re reviewed those in
some detail and I just want to highlight
four in particular there's the thriving
communities
fund which is where we can fund projects
that are um as it says on the tin um to
to ensure our communities Thrive there's
one called strategic efficiencies so
that is um projects that within the
councils to say we need needed a new it
system for something or there was a
particular back office type process that
we wanted to um get changed so that's a
fund for that there's the Gateway 14
Reserve as I've mentioned and also the
we've done a separate reserve for the
skills and Innovation Center on Gateway
14 um with regards to the HRA now that's
a a particularly challenging position as
you all have seen um we've all and I say
when I say we I mean all the the team
Finance team housing and so on have been
looking at an HRA business plan modeling
this over 30 years and that's currently
being done and I hopefully um we we all
as a council will be able to implement
that um in a couple of in a couple of
months time hopefully in
March but based on some of the work
that's going on in that the H account
shows an increase in rents of 7.7% which
is CPI plus one um and without this we'd
not be able to produce um a balanced
budget but you will also note in terms
of the rent amounts increasing that
that's due partly as well because of the
increased amount R Rental Properties we
now have and changes in the way that the
rent is calculated um which our head of
housing has has bought in that are used
in other
councils however costs have increased um
quite significantly um and there's a
couple of key issues from 23 24 so one
was the backlog of repairs of
effectively with um the council is doing
two years of repairs in one year for 23
24 um there's also an interest
calculation error which you'll see in
your papers but also the interest rate
increase has obviously caused um cost to
go
up and excuse me the reserves for the
HRA show that um they've been reviewed
but they to ensure that a working
balance is available so that's all I've
got to say at the moment chair but I'm
happy to answer any questions and if I
can't I'm hop hoping the the team to my
right will be able to if they very
technical questions thank you very
much thank you very much councelor eburn
um so when we do ask questions it'd be
quite good if we would clear whether
they're HRA questions or general fund
questions um just to help with the
officers understand exactly where
they're coming from they could easily be
both um do we have any um questions to
start off with i i can come councelor
PE right my first question is that it's
actually a request but formed as a
question would it be possible in the
future to have the numbers parts of
these reports on in spreadsheet format
as well as
PDF easier to work on them
um I I'm happy to answer that chair
because um it's something that I like to
see because it's kind of useful to be
able to kind of almost for yourself kind
of say you know what if this went up by
a few percent or down by a few percent
and so on and and um the the issue with
it is that um in the finance system
everything is incorporated together so
that um to for them to kind of pull out
just the one spreadsheet with with the
numbers is quite tricky but yes we
should certainly look at that for the
future thank you
you thank you um
in in regards to um Revenue um the
general fund summary um grants and
income there's a section there um sales
fees and
charges I'll just give you a second to
find
that um down 10
7% you can just let me know what they
what that's referenced
to excuse me uh sales fees and charges
um obviously the planning income is the
major change there so planning fees are
we're looking at a deficit Budget on
budget of about 6
700,000 um even when you account for a
25% statutory increase in the in the
charges the um
it might be um me but the movement's
different to
um on the other side on the general fun
fund pressures where it's um droping
planning income are they two different
are they two different things
there yeah the yeah well the dropping
planning income is$
692 yeah and obviously fees and charges
have gone up you know some fees and
charges have risen so the overall
downward is 580 because we've right okay
okay oh so sorry that is um that's
actually a cost not that's not our fees
and charges that we
receive have I got that wrong so we
charge fees we we charge fees for
planning yeah and they those fees have
dropped by about 25% yeah and what we
were forecast last year was was a lot
was based on years before and years
before but it's dropped considerably so
there's loss as it were but we're not
getting in those fees right by 692
th000 but what we are but what we have
done is we've reviewed all the fees and
charges and there are others that will
have increased slightly so they will
have meant that rather than that figure
being on on your page 11 in that table
the the figure being it's 580 because we
yeah we've got some of those fees and
charges have gone up as it were to
compensate for the right okay so yeah
those figes would never be the same
right yeah including some of the
planning fees are able to be increased
but it's not compensating for that
overall downward
turn okay great um and um a minimum
Revenue position and struggled a little
bit with what that was that's one of my
favorites I might hand you over to Karen
on this
one can minimum Revenue provision MRP is
a charge to the revenue budget which we
have to set statutorily central
government depart departments duu say
that we have to set this amount aside in
our budget and what it's intended to do
it's a cost to the revenue budget of
being able to um fund any principal
amount of any borrowing we've done in
the
future so it only occurs when for
example when we've actually done some
borrowing to fund a capital program for
example then we set aside the MRP that's
determined by the MRP policy which goes
up to council each year to be approved
by Council as part of the treasury
management strategy right okay and
that's the charge to the revenue budget
and it's the consequence of the council
borrowing so we know exactly what that
was going to be year on year um because
of our policy it's a calculation like
most estimates in the budget based on
the the policy that Council div um
agrees each year but also an estimate of
how much borrowing we're likely to incur
in the in the year ahead so it's an
estimate it's not a definite but it's
it's the estimate taking all things into
consideration okay thank
you um okay are there any um councelor
scarf um I've got three questions on the
HRA would you prefer me to ask them
separately or
all together I'm sorry I I was coughing
councelor scarf I didn't hear a word
I've got three questions on the HRA uh
would you prefer me to ask them all
together or one at a time and get an
answer um I what would officers like
would you like it broken up or it go for
it okay I'll go I'll go for it then um
the first one is on the Assumption on
the right to buy properties there are uh
an assumption that we will sell 17
properties
and this will contribute to the increase
uh of
2.93 um how confident are we bearing in
in mind the market conditions interest
rates Etc that we will achieve that is
it a conservative estimate for right to
buy it's a question I usually ask at
every meeting uh annually but I'm
concerned obviously that this year in
particular it to balance the budget we
need to ensure that we actually reach
that figure so is that figure slightly
below what we expect and therefore more
realistic or is it
overachieving that's the first question
um the second question um the portfolio
holder referred to uh not only the
7.7 uh percent proposed at this moment
rent increase but uh indicated there
were other factors that would increase
that income I wonder if you give us a
little bit more detail on that so that
we know what what they are um and then
finally um on the uh unaccounted for
1.96 interest uh that was found um we
we're presuming obviously that this will
not happen again but can you give us
some Assurance as to how you dealt with
it and how you would ensure that it
doesn't happen again because that's
quite a sum of money thank
you thank you through you chair if I may
um the Assumption of the right to buy um
over the past sort of 10 15 years right
to buyers have ranged from kind of 10 a
year up to 25 um and you can look back
anyone can look at them on the
government's website to see how many um
mids um sold each you know were right to
buys for mids each year so I would say
that 17 is probably fairly conservative
and fairly sort of average-ish figure
you know in that there have been years
when it's been up to 25 but there's also
been years when it's been down to 10 so
um that's on on that Point um on the
rent increase um an example of other
things that have been taken into account
are that there is um being introduced
what's known as anyday renting so that
previously at mids you would have a rent
day so if you so I don't know what day
of the week it is say it's Wednesday but
if you moved in on a Wednesday you don't
pay your if you moved in on a Monday you
wouldn't pay your rent until
Wednesday and just by the day you move
in you pay you start paying rent that
that cumulative amount across the whole
portfolio has has led to kind of you
know increases in in rent and it's it's
a
standard um process that's used
everywhere really and we're not quite
sure why it hasn't been used here but um
that that's one of the things for
example on that front um plus things
like which you'll probably be aware of
in this um committee things like voids
shortening void times so we've got more
properties available um more quickly
um and by doing things like ensuring
when when we know someone's um moving
out to actually go into their place
beforehand to see what needs to be done
so you've you're not waiting too long to
do to do some work for
example on the um issue with the
interest rate um
calculation that that was discovered
because
the because of going through the figures
with a fine tooth cone basically
and within the 30-year business plan um
that that's a kind of model that's got
about
90 kind of sections to it worksheets as
it were covering absolutely every aspect
of the housing revenue account and it
just by absolutely going through that in
detail that was realized that there was
a there was an error there although
equally one would say you
know perhaps that should have been you
know I don't if that occurred in
previous years or whatever but it is it
is there and but it's also because the
within that model you
can't that that can't now happen if you
know what I mean because of how that's
set up um so we would you know not
expect anything like that to to happen
again and obviously the other bit of
that is the actual interest rate
increase so obviously that plays you
know a big part and yes they've slightly
gone down but they're still much higher
than anyone was expecting a couple of
years ago thank you
chair thank you very much um counc
Pearson this is um a a query this is the
first year I've looked at this so
forgive me if I'm being completely dim
but on the HRA budget you've got a
figure for depreciation in there so does
that mean that this isn't a cash budget
it's an it's a p&l budget
um the depreciation on HRA is a way we
have accounting for it's the way all
hras are managed and it's based on our
stock
valuation and we then use that
depreciation it's not depreciated in the
way that normal a normal p&l would be
depreciated that Dee ation is then used
for um repairs and maintenance in the
capital side but repairs on the capital
side so you can then see that picked up
on the capital accounts thank
you thank you um in here as well we've
got um and um Tom Barker's here this
might be quite useful we've got no
um no um rise in business rates for Ev
um for renewable energy sites does that
mean I know we don't know exactly where
we are with business um rates yet but
does that mean that we won't have any
business new business rates coming in
from solar Farms um because I've seen
several plan
applications um po I can answer that
chair I mean potentially we might I mean
previously um the um renewable energy
business rates have been split out but
because there's you know and I think
with with regards to say um business
rates coming on stream they do take
quite a while to come to appear in the
budget so and they're a year behind as
well in terms of how that is is
calculated so I would have thought that
the following year 25 26 will we'll see
that so we almost need it to get going
wait a year and then the budget will be
of these business rates from the solar
solar Farms that are running yeah and
and I think I'll make a note of that
chair and to you know maybe to update
members um on business rates in general
once when we have more information on
that okay thank you um I'll go back to
the floor are there any um questions
from the floor councelor Pearson again
and then councelor
scarf sorry this is my last one um on on
the general fund I was having a bit of a
problem tying up uh the transfers to
from reserves
figures um in table two there's a figure
for transfers transfer from
reserves and then there's the the
table further down where's it
gone table five and I couldn't I I
didn't understand how those tied up
because the figures are
different
um thank you for that um question this
is something that I too have grappled
with in terms of trying to add things up
via um Excel spreadsheets and so on um
but I think if you um I can take you
through that outside of the meeting but
it's it in terms of the the reserves on
page 15 at table five yeah um when you
take out the um gate the Gateway 14
dividend and the skills and Innovation
and a few of the other ones that aren't
being used in the general fund then you
get to that figure do you yes you do I
have checked it so um thank you and I
just um one of my colleagues just wants
to add to that
thanks thank you and councelor Scar oh
sorry um I was just going to add to the
explanation some of the reserves are
being used to fund capital instead of
the revenue budget for next financial
year particularly the skills and
Innovation Center and that was approved
at cabinet in
December thank you now councelor scar
thank you chair um back to the general
fund again then um obviously this is
another one-year
settlement uh the sixth in a row uh
which causes I think councils a great
deal of disqui because you can't plan uh
very easily what steps are this Council
taking to Lobby government to try and
get a better funding settlement regime
so we've got some certainty in the
future um thank you chair thank you for
the question um are the leader of the
council Andrew melan has been um working
with the district council Network to do
that to lobby and he was recently at an
event in Parliament last week um to do
that very same thing um so there are
ongoing kind of um lobbying opport
unities which we're making the most of
um but I agree the the the key issue is
not being able to plan long term and you
know we we just do do not know one year
to the next and the point that um much
of the government funding that we
receive isn't um I think we were told
what it was going to be on the 18th of
December so you know budgets are well
underw at that time and if you can't
plan until you know
the month before you're actually
supposed to be kind of publishing papers
like this for this type of meeting it's
very very difficult and if anyone's got
any influence of the government I'd
quite like them to actually you know get
that get a better long-term position and
maybe something will come up in the
March um spring statement whatever it's
called so um but I doubt it but we we
will will'll keep at
it thank you um also in this um I've got
a it's not under employees but is the
political assistance um money factored
into this yes it is yeah yeah where
where would that
be that it's it's in employees oh it
does go in employees sorry I had a
feeling that we said it wasn't going to
go in there when it was going to come
out of another budget or yeah okay thank
you so that's that's all part of that
increase in the cost of the um the staff
well CH if I might the main the main
cost increase for staff is is the
increments and the and the pay increase
so that's the yeah that's the main as
always with every budget it's always
like quite a big factor isn't it in the
budget the um as as staff move up they
um they need to be paid more which is
excellent you know because they're
getting more better at their job and
more qualified but um okay um I'll go
back to the floor now if there's
anything Council the white
if you would like to ask any questions
now councilor Whitehead is isn't part of
the committee but um I will allow him to
ask questions just for the sake of
scrutiny than thank you chair yeah I got
a couple of questions perhaps three take
one at a
time um on page 18 we've got well sorry
on the top of page 17 the dwellings rent
goes up 2.8 million uh which is a
17.2% increase compared to the previous
year's budget and um the explanations
are set out in 5.8
5.9 but I'm struggling to sort of find
where the 2.9 in total comes from um the
on a 7.7% increase it's going up 2.9
Million um last year's budget was a 7%
increase which generated
1.26 million the year before a 4%
increase generated
600,000 so it's struggle to see where
7.7% increase can generate more than
double those you know those figures I
think have you finished asking your
question well yes councelor yeah
councelor eburn um thank you chair yes
well that's um that increase as as as
you said and as says in 5.8 5.9 is from
those those factors and the ones I've
explained earlier when um Council scarf
asked the question um in addition um
councilor whad it's a 53 we year so
there was an extra week in there um but
yes it does it it does all add
up would you'd like to keep going yeah
well if I was on the committee I think I
think it'd be useful to have what's
called a bridge chart which shows where
the different components make that
because I'm taking everything into
account even the 53 53 week uh year
about
300,000 right to buys takes off about
50,000 change invoice takes about
32,000 um and uh I still think there's
about a million pound figure that I
can't justify unless there's a lot more
houses assumed in the in the next year's
budget yes you're correct Council I
there are a lot more houses in there
than there were last the previous year
86 so it's um isn't it it's it's made a
big
difference I think it's 86 houses um or
something along those lines um but um
you it it almost feels like you could do
with a Blackboard um to show exactly um
what you mean but um a um a bridging
chart could you just tell me what a
bridging chart is because it might be a
recommendation if it's useful for
counselors
start oh turn can you turn your
microphone on you start with a base
figure where you started start from you
say add perhaps 1.3 million for the rent
increase another small increase for the
voids um probably a decrease from right
to buys show where the 53 weeks comes in
and then show where the additional
houses come in know you're going from a
to be in
steps where moment we just got a 2.9
Million one stuff if you like which I
think would be quite useful for
counselors in the future just so we can
work out exactly um where things are
um are have you any more questions
councelor Whitehead just a couple more
yeah please I'm surprised the service
charges Inc comes up
35.5% it just seems a a large figure off
the current years base which presumably
has had the bulk of the inflation type
increases with the utility cost slow
going down and everything it just seems
a high figure
35% um thank you chair um as as Council
wad will know um surfice the
um surfice charge isn't the full cost of
the service charge on sheltered
accommodation and that's been an issue
for many many years um and um that's
something that's just that's been looked
at very closely um and even with that
increase it still won't be um covering
the costs thank you
chair yeah thank you and um the final
question relates to um the overall
increase in interest charges over both
the general fund and the um
HRA um last year's budget had 4.2
million this year's budget over the two
has 7.5 million so um it's quite a big
increase um the treasury management
report at the end of September showed
112 million of loans at an average rate
of about three and a half% it generated
3.9 million of Interest so it's
difficult to understand how the interest
has gone from 3.9 4 million up to 7
million bearing in mind that 77% of the
loans mature after two years so 34s of
the interest is fixed rates beyond the
life of this budget so it's difficult to
see how the the rest of it has generated
so much more
interest even on the general fund um
unless there's an awful lot of capital
borrowing that we haven't we can't see
in here and bearing in mind the Gateway
14 dividend should be bringing cash into
the company into the council it just
seems strange why the interests have
gone up so
much um thank you chair thank you
Council WAD for that um you you'll know
very well Council whad that we've got a
very large amount of um short-term
borrowing at mids suffk um in fact on
the H I think there's 32 um million
pounds of short-term borrowing and the
interest rate on that has obviously gone
up and is around 5 point something
percent at the moment so that makes a
that's a big impact um and um the longer
term borrowing is says at lower lower
rates but the shortterm is at a much
higher rate plus also when we
um borrow internal Ally so even for
example on the general fund with the
Gateway 14 income if there was a project
that was kind of borrowing from in Via
internal we've still got to charge a
rate of interest and we would have to
charge the rate of interest that is
whatever is at the moment
5.25 so um that adds considerably and
that's one of the things about Council
you know finances as you as you'll know
well it's um you know there there are
particular rules that governments say
that we have to um have to stick to and
so that's the rationale I don't one my
colleagues wants to add anything to
that um just to add that the other
component of borrowing is not only your
fixed term loans and as the counselor
Ean said the short-term borrowing but we
also have to make an estimate of how
much longer term borrowing or short-term
borrowing will be doing through the
capital program to fund the capital
program so again we don't have a a
crystal ball obviously in February of
how much capital expenditure we're
likely to spend during the financial
year but we have to take a reasonable
Assumption of how much we would need to
go out in order to to finance the
capital
program and and if I could just come
back on that obviously interest rates
you know two years ago were much lower
um prior to the
um particular event in September um two
years ago but the um so at the time no
one was forecasting interest rates were
going to be over
5% so it's even when we get advice from
our um treasury advisors it's very
difficult to actually um as as you as
you know councelor wad very difficult to
actually forecast what the interest rate
will be going forward and make um
provision for that thank
you yeah thank thank you for those
answers I think it's you know it's
difficult to really see the whole
picture without seeing the the capital
budget and seeing where where the
pressures are from there so look forward
to seeing that in due
course and I think we're getting towards
the end of questions now but I will ask
with a um a scrutiny
um cliche um how does this budget align
with the long-term plans of the council
is this are we carrying on in the
direction that we need to be or do you
think there's there's trouble ahead and
please councelor re um I think
um a couple of things in terms of longer
term in general um we have no idea what
government funding will be and so um we
need to ensure that we are have got a
robust sensible financial management for
the next 10 years and by using the
resources and by resources I mean the
people the places as well as the
finances in terms of how we how we meet
that um with regards to um the new
administration's priorities um that's
something that obviously you can we'll
be discussing in in probably in more
detail um at the next stage of of the
the budget um suffice to say that we
have got great Ambitions with um various
things that we want to achieve within
our priorities but the from a day-to-day
perspective um this this budget does
meet that dayto day one of the things I
would like to say is that um
and I we want to have the discussion um
with your yourself chair and the vice
chair um for next year is that we very
much want to start the budget process uh
um much earlier and get much more
involvement from all counselors because
just to suddenly put a load of figures
in front of you you know a month before
we're going to be approving you know yes
I agree you had the um assumptions
discussion before but I think it would
be much more helpful to have that more
rounded discussion earlier and um we we
as an administration had discussions
with the um leaders of the two
opposition groups um to get some input
from them but we would really like to
see going forward that we do budget
discussions much earlier in the process
thank you yeah thank you councelor eam
we um yeah we did have the assumptions
meeting but it still feels like there's
not a lot of time before this has to go
to full Council and it's some I don't
know whether you can never sort of take
the um the stress well for you it must
be very stressful for as a um as a
scrutiny um chairman it's quite is quite
um stressful because you're sort of
thinking this has got to be done we got
to get this through and if there's any
problems they need to be um sorted out
um before that meeting so I can't
imagine what it's like for the portfolio
holder but um no that's um that's great
so um oh councelor row a question um
I've got a couple questions which come
one about just being new to council so
not knowing quite how it works and one
about kind of how papers are laid out is
why I've left them to the end um one it
would be helpful if there was a bit of
explanation for kind because brackets
are used in lots of tables and to kind
of make pay make information more
accessible to kind of wider public it'd
be useful so you wouldn't need to have
some sort of account sensy knowledge to
be able to see kind of easily understand
the tables um because brackets wouldn't
necessar be as easy to understand um for
example for general public and my SEC
the second bit which I'm not entirely
sure of is with the discrepancy of the
interest rates and quite how like the
auditing
side of stuff works because like
presumably that would that's sort of
thing which would be picked up by
Auditors but I've also kind of heard
that there's like a national approach so
could I have a bit more information as I
knew and don't
know um thank thank you thanks shair
thank you councelor for your questions
firstly um yes I agree it's with regards
to how the the the accounting the
accounts work um in ter terms of you
know um in Council accounts if it's got
brackets around it that's actually a
positive whereas if you were in a
business you would you would be really
worried if you had big figures with
brackets around them so um you know and
I agree I think it's helpful to kind of
put in a footnote somewhere saying you
know this is how the numbers you know or
or or even you know some kind of not
quite glossery but something like that
explaining this is how Council accounts
work I mean it's hard enough for us let
alone anybody in the public trying to
trying to look at it and assess it and
even some of the question questions like
minimum Revenue provision and things
like that I mean What on earth does that
mean to anybody so um yes no that's a
you know any more explanation to get
people to understand it um and read it
would be would be good um with regards
to audit
um uh some of you on the committee might
know that the um audits for um the
council the external audit is um a long
way overdue which is the same position
as an awful lot of councils in the
country
um and in fact I think
council's accounts get bounced for NHS
accounts for example so even some
councils have had their audit started
and then stopped because an NHS trust
has come in and and they've been told
down tools you've got to audit the NHS
one in priority over the um Council one
so relying on external audit is a is an
issue because we are so far out of date
um there are sort of internal auditing
um processes that have gone through um
so hopefully that would pick up um some
of those some of those points I don't
know if any of my colleagues want to add
anything to
that if I may um the government has
recently announced that they have a plan
um to eliminate all the backlog of
external of audits uh for local
government so they've decreed that all
the audits must be finalized by
September of this year now we were
awaiting um detailed regulations from
them that what will this mean in actual
practice um will it mean that the
Auditors will come and do a light touch
audit for example just to give the
minimum Assurance on the accounts but
the national picture is such that
government feels that they have to
intervene in order to get the backlog of
audits done and for these two councils
for your Council um the last order was
201920 so we have three years of
backdated audits to do as well as
closing the current Financial year 2023
24 could I just um follow on and so who
does the external audit for um the
council it's erston young chair who do
an awful lot of council oh okay and and
I think there's there's literally you
know no other accounting you know firms
with capacity as that's what I was going
to say you you're forced to use very few
and very high highly demanded Auditors
and that that's the problem yeah okay
all right thank you um councelor
Whitehead um put another question if
that's allowed chair yeah please um in
the um November assumptions brought to
on it was the Assumption was that the uh
zero change in council tax whereas this
this this one here is a 2% increase um
given the 2 million surplus this year
and the 1.2 million surplus next year
and the 20 million pound dividend coming
in from Gateway 14 which just represents
about half the total site there um I
wonder what justification is to put the
council tax up I think um I think that
might be a bit more political than um
scrutiny that um that question councelor
Whitehead um if if you'd like to answer
that but um we need to be careful
because obviously full Council will be
the time to um to talk about decisions
that are made by the administration but
um yes I mean that you know I was going
to make make the same point that we you
know there'll be every opportunity to
discuss that but obviously what we
wanted to do was be very open and honest
and that is we are um considering
putting the counil tax up by 2% so we
wanted ensure that you saw it
and I think that's the difference is we
could have said oh we're going to wait
until a day before full Council so no
one gets the opportunity to see see what
that really is um plus you know the
comment that I made earlier in terms of
we have no idea what long-term
Government funding is um so we need to
make sure that for the next decade at
least we are um in a secure financial
position and we're fin very financially
well managed um and you know with
regards to the
um the Surplus um that you you've
mentioned that needs to be um that needs
to be spent within our communities on
particular projects and so on that our
communities have asked for and including
the Gateway 14 funding and that is not
for day-to-day the day-to-day budget and
day-to-day funding of
Staff councilor Whitehead okay a
scrutiny question I that a nonpolitical
question final one um in the um e mar
Reserves on page 15 there's 848 th000
shown under
covid-19 and we take from that in the
next year
17,745
um at that rate the co reserves got got
a run runoff rate of 47 years I just
wondered why why why you know what the
intention with the covid reserve is if
it's only being used so
slowly
um thank you chair thank you Council wad
um if there are um if there is areas of
work that are have um been impacted due
to covid then they can be then that
funding can be used but it is very
specific it we have to prove that it is
as a result of um
covid it's interesting we've got two
staff members today off with covid so
the cost is still um carrying on as we
speak um Council scarf well it's a
followup really to that because
um another Council that meets here um is
using covid funding to support uh their
General budget this year and that was a
question that was raised at at their
meeting is any of that Reserve liable to
go back to central government if unspent
or is it our
money um I understand it's not going
back to
government
okay thank you so um I'll probably go to
debate now if um everyone's ready to do
that um so we've had a lot of questions
it's been really interesting I've I've
written down while we're doing this um a
few things that recommendations but
things that we might ask for for next
time around um the first thing is that
the um the
capital buring with the um interest
received we've got that certain amount
we can reference that to the treasury
report um to see which of which um how
much money is um leaves whatever
interest rate when if that's gets to
maturity or um what whatever you call it
um it would be nice to have that in
these um in in this just so we can say
right so that's the cost of the money
borrowed the 117 million or whatever
that's Borrowed by the
council and um then this is for future
Capital spend councilor eurn would you
like to um thank you chair the the just
to to um comment the um the actual
borrowing from the general fund that's
in the um that'll be at the Joint audit
and standards committee because it'll be
within the treasury management so all
that detail is there if anybody wants to
um read it and look at that um and with
regards to the HRA there um will be a um
in terms of the capital program when
that comes forward in the next off
papers there's a table in that with that
with that information so that it's that
information is either currently
available it's currently available but
it's very hard to find especially for
new members if you're trying to
reference and make sure everything adds
up to and I think a certain number if if
I may chair it might be good to put a
link maybe to that particular paper
within this report so so um counselors
can then reference it yeah that would be
really good actually I know when we were
talking about this in the um briefing I
sent um the um a screenshot of the
treasury um um report through to another
counsel so they could see where I what
what they asked what our borrowing was
and obviously in that treasury report
you've got exactly where what's borrowed
from where and um if new counselors
could find that I think that' be ever so
helpful um also the
um the um
Bridge chart for
um um income from rents from HRA I'm
doing it now not same whether it's H or
general fund I'm talking about in the H
account the um the um the bridge chart
that shows where how we got to the
amount of rent that's been received in
the new budget um you know what's moved
around and where which um yeah um ch I
may haven't checked for colleagues
that's something that can be produced
yeah okay thank you um and um yeah um
councilor Ro was saying about more
graphics and things just to make these
more accessible for people I think that
is um I think with Graphics I think you
can um you you you could maybe um use
them a little bit more I think
previously previously we've had like pie
charts of where incomes come from and
everything like that and I I I might see
that when I get the actual full Council
report as normal and this is this has
been a very good like cut down
streamlined paper for this scrutiny
committee but um they are useful um and
the other thing I wrote down was
external auditing which um I don't think
we can do a lot about but it does strike
me as it's so important for that
external audit that we can't seem to be
able to to find someone to do um cuz um
to think that they haven't been done by
three for three years really does worry
me
but there's nothing that can be done
about that but I wrote it down anyway so
um I just thought I'd share that with
you um would anyone else like to talk on
this councilor scarf uh yeah I mean we
we've talked about the fact that
obviously the council has a lot of new
members uh and even for those members
who've been on the council budgets are
not necessarily our speciality so I
think as much information that we can
have would be good as much information
that the public could understand which
Council Ro mentioned would would be
really good um perhaps for the budget
papers that come to council we can have
some more detail about the service
charges and the impacts there as well um
one recommendation I know that we're
already doing it because we've had the
answer today but uh I think we should
continue as a council to recognize that
we've got to got to Lobby central
government for more than a one-year
funding settlement at the time I know
it's an issue for all councils but
unless we really Lobby I don't think
we'll achieve anything and I wonder
whether there's any benefit in um
actually lobbying our members of
parliament as well uh rather than direct
to government and put pressure on them
because they must be getting pressure
from all local authorities across suffer
I think you know it's it's a disgraceful
thing to to to expect you to have a
one-year funding settlement it gives no
security at all and it's a sixth in a
row and um speaking as a member who's
been longer serving we were used to a
number of funding years settlements
coming out so we could that could inform
the medium-term financial strategy and
all sorts of
things yes um totally agree um councilor
scoff I was actually without name
dropping I was a lunch with the Chan of
the exchange and that exact question was
um asked of him um and um there wasn't
there wasn't a clear answer on getting
funding then but I think yeah I totally
agree I think um that um we do need to
Lobby in some way or do do what we can
to try and get that because that that's
a problem every single year isn't it um
any other comments to be
made so we got to um right we got to
think about what we're going to um say
about this um does um does anyone have
any other recommendations they want to
um they want to put
in councilor
Pearson only to add in um Council Ro
said about charts but also a glossery of
accounting information sorry could you
say that again um a glossery or some
information about County terms yeah okay
yeah we'll put that
down what we could do is um whether we
need to actually make these
recommendations or whether the fact that
we've discussed it in this
meeting um is enough for um the officers
to take that away with them I don't know
councelor
Carter just regarding the accessibility
of information um to make it more easy
for individual um object permanence well
you have um certain products like 8way
14 in several different charts you have
other ones if you had a single chart
with project with all the information
regarding that
project um if it's something that's
mentioned multiple times if that is been
specified as one single chart and then
another one for different chart it would
make it a lot easier because when you
have objective permanance you can read
something read a figure see it again and
it's completely written by what's
written there so it's it certainly would
make it more accessible for other
individuals as well to to understand the
read is that when they duplicate to show
you like um the um you've got the table
and then you've
got for the the main pressures and
things in the next table is that yes
yeah so that you yeah if you could if if
if there's some way of showing that
those numbers were the same numbers as
well um you to carry them over that
they've been taken through I don't know
I don't know quite how that's done but
um yeah certainly for an individual like
myself disc calcular it's I got that and
that and it's like yeah I know not very
easy it's um yeah if it's the same
number sometimes you're adding them
together and you you think well that
doesn't that doesn't work out the um so
um let me just have a look at the
recommendation on
this
let my papers all get mixed up one
second so so this is for um this is for
noting um so um if we um do we need a
proposal for noting this yeah so i'
quite happy to take a proposal for this
to be noted um councelor scarf and a
seconder um councelor Piper you would
maybe just before councelor R um and um
we just we can just talk about um
recommendations we want to put in there
I think we do want to have a
recommendation saying that um we need
more information for the um Capital um
for the interest receivable um that we
talked about earlier where those um
where that interest has come from um
outside of um the that could be
referencing in the
um in the um treasury report but also I
think we have got that
Capital um I I know where to find the
treasury report the um the capital
expenditure um projects side of things I
don't know where to find that so that
would that would be good to include that
um maybe a bit of um charting on rent
rental income from the for the HRA
account um the um Lobby to would like to
um Lobby the government to get more than
one year or you know it's not even a
year
so um you know a longer term yeah view
on where we're going to be
um and also a gloss
of terms used in here but um would
anyone like to add any other coun scar
well um chair I mean I think um the
portfolio had has referred to the way
that they hope that the budget will go
in future years in terms of the internal
mechanisms of the council uh and from a
scrutiny process I think that's to be
welcome so I think we should welcome
that new approach moving forward with
the budget setting process yeah
is
that is that all right did you get
those yeah we can sit down and um look
at those if you like what we can do is
um if there's no um if there's no other
further recommendations anyone wants to
um put what we'll do is we'll have a
short break thank you very much officers
you can um you can go now and um I'll
sit down and um we'll work through these
and then we'll vote on them when we get
back so um yeah thank you very much
we'll we'll have a short well I don't
know let's have a 10-minute break thank
you
thank you very much um for your patience
we've um we've had a look at
recommendations um we've now got
something that you can um look at and um
hopefully we can vote on quite soon
um Beth you are you going to read them
out or Jo me to them yeah you'll read
them out okay I'll let betham go through
the recommendations that we've got down
and then we can discuss whether they
need tweaking or whatever so the
recommendations are that the draft
Revenue budgets are set out in the
report for the 2425 general fund and
housing revenue account budgets be noted
that further information on an interest
receivable and capital expenditure be
included to provide a breakdown of
interest for all projects in debt the
the HRA budget includes a table breaking
down the increase on dwelling dwelling
rents there a breakdown on serviceing
service charges in be included that
lobbying of central government on the
one-year funding settlement be increased
being increased to be continued that the
new approach to budget setting be
welcomed by the aie and scrutiny
committee that information on projects
being present that informational
projects be presented in a summary in
the report for accessibility that
including Bridge charting graphics and a
glossery to provide member with further
Clarity on information provided in the
report
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is 684 that's
unanimous thank you very much that
unanimous so that's carried um thank you
everyone um and thank you councel eburn
for that was a really good um session
there some good
answers um right so um we go to item 8
MOS
2306 um forthcoming decisions list do
members have any comments on
that
no thank you very much um so the next
one is the action tracker MOS 23 07 OV
and scrutiny Committee Action tracker do
members have any
comments on
that do you want a few minutes just to
I'll give you a few a little while just
to go through
that
for
oh counil the scarf um thank you J
there's um one item where the status is
not started which is um The Wider
publicity campaign for Resident staff
and counselors regarding materials that
cannot be put into the sewage system I
wondered if this um is an opportune time
we have discussed um Recycling and what
can be put into the bins uh because
there there's a general confusion on
that as well and a lot of the bins that
are collected for recycling are rejected
25% which is a huge volume which then
goes to the energy from waste facility
whether we have the opportunity to
combine those two and use our mail out
for the council
tax to put in such a leaflet whether
that was feasible or not or perhaps that
could be explored because I feel that
that's opportunity where we're we're
emailing out to every household uh and
we might be able to do that and then
recycling uh reminder because I mean it
is confusing some items are obviously
put in deliberately but other items very
like coffee cups and things like that
you know whe that might be an idea yeah
I think that's a very good idea I'm not
quite sure what the mechanism is for um
putting that in and with Alysia not here
I think think maybe we can um um that
was on the that was on the action
tracker for the
um um 18 0923 wasn't it and um there is
actually um there still ongoing parts of
that which um maybe that could be
included with that but I think we'll
wait for Alysia to um get back and
um yeah put that put that to her that
that should be included with the ongoing
work on there
um but it's um I think that's a very
sensible um idea counc Scott I mean I
was I was just conscious J that you
know some time has passed on that one
that's the only one that's not started
that the rest are completed or ongoing
but whether the opportunity would be
arising very shortly you know for that
kind of information campaign to be used
alongside the council tax bill uh
element
yeah that's it and the fact that it's
not started as well isn't really that's
something that we really need to be um
looking at because that's going to
that's going to be six months before we
um know it isn't it and
um you know it's it's just it's been
around for a long time so yeah we'll um
we'll follow up with that and um we'll
look at that being added to it yeah
thank
you um any other action
tracker questions no okay so um yeah
that's for noting so we don't need to do
any more about that so the next thing is
the um Mid suffer Oban scrutiny work
plan um for comments what I'll do is
I'll give you a bit of time to have a
look at that as well um sorry if you've
already looked at it but um just give
members a bit of time just to um see if
there's anything in there that stands
out
also if there's anything you'd like us
to be looking at as well this is will be
quite a good time to put that forward
and we'll take that through to um other
meetings to um try and get it in the
agenda um councilor scarf okay I mean
one of the topics still to be timet is
the social housing one uh which was a
review of existing Cas load and
resources needed for repairs to meet new
and improved standards now I know
there's an awful lot of work going on
within housing uh uh on that and
particularly in terms of the housing
revenue account um 30-year plan um I
would like to see us timetable that as
early as we could uh whether the 20th of
May is too early or not not I don't know
but perhaps we can have some discussions
with the officers uh just to get that
into the timetable because I'm conscious
from April and May we have no topics and
obviously we then start another year and
we don't want to start another year with
a couple of months with no topics
against them I'm not not for having
meetings about meetings but you know I
think yeah no definitely we need to get
that one in time that we can use don't
we because we'll we we could easily end
up with that being absolutely Chu block
and I'm having too much in a meeting um
let me just write that
down um councelor row I was wondering
whether it touches on not things and we
mentioned it today about having glossy
making things more readable whe there's
whether it's worth having a look at kind
of our Communications and how an
accessibility of
communications um at this
um panel um given what has happened in
the past and what we've raised in a few
what has been raised in a few different
places so would that sorry would that be
communication between officers and
counselors or the public or generally
all communication um with the public I'd
say with the public yeah yeah
which I think is a very good sort of
topic to look about uh
accessibility um let me put that down
and that's something that
we'll um talk about in our um our
Chairman's
briefings yeah it's everyone had a good
look at that now it's amazing how
quickly we've um oh
councilor Carter I was just going to say
it's amazing how quickly we've got
through to um a gap in the diary on this
committee because I remember um
councilor scaf um will hopefully agree
with me and we we started off and it was
absolutely Chua block for a long time
and we I thought how are we going to fit
any work into there and we sort of come
out the other side and we've we got a
bit of a gap not not too many months
away which is um which is interesting
councilor Carter um thank Thank you
regarding the accessibility and
Communications we could also look at
internal as well regarding communication
uh the layout
of um doc documents and
um presentations so actually have
accessible presentations and one thing I
noticed when you come into this
building and if we had members of public
in the building what we don't cover here
we have the fire access but we don't
cover here in briefings regard the
procedures for if it's a wheelchair be
removal things like that so if we had
accessibility of information and safety
briefings for the public and a whole
when they're coming into the meetings it
might be an idea if we could look at
look at that to um add it in possibly
there's a number of accessibility things
that we could it's a very broad subject
that we could it does almost sound a
little bit like a work group to me now
that kind of thing to actually look into
um where we um where we might fall a
little bit short on accessibility and
with when we're you know in giving
instructions like fire drills and things
like that um I think that's definitely
one to take away and just um look but um
it does seem to me like a small work
group could be working on that and come
to scrutiny with um with things that've
been looked at and that could that could
be a meeting like that councelor scarf
but taking out what councelor C said
maybe um the way to do it would be to do
an information bulletin so that we we we
can then be appraised of what because
there must be procedures in place but we
could be appraised of what those
procedures are we could look at the
information bulletin and then go forward
from there if we have uh any concerns
about about that that maybe that' be the
easiest way of doing it um then we'd
know what the up-to-date position is
because there's there's policies and
procedures on everything in the building
I'm sure but yeah that's true actually
we don't know what they are unless we're
user of those policies or procedures
necessarily you're absolutely right it's
um yeah it's just that they haven't been
in front of us they've probably existed
for a long time but um yeah okay thank
you very much um I think that's all
right um to move on and um that's for
noting as well so we don't need to um
worry
anymore about voting so um it is it's
just gone 11 o'cl two minutes past 11
um and I'll conclude the business um our
next meeting is um on the 19th of
February at 9:30 a.m. so um I'll close
the meeting thank you very
much